you brought up some imagery that was
quite shocking and then I couldn't go
anywhere without people talk to me about
it they loved it but I want to just
bring it up because I'm wondering if
you've if you're thinking on this matter
has involved at all first take us
through what you said last well I didn't
plan on even talking about that
I stood up and described my vagina to
you guys because not these people these
are these it's a support group we
brought everyone who saw everyone who
was there a group of people who feel bad
about Nicky's vagina it's okay just to
catch you guys up it uh I don't I'm not
one of these girls that just like when
they stand it's just like a little line
and it's like what could be in their
minds lega I described you last time as
a hastily packed suitcase and I think
that was the industry that really image
got in my head and it's in there about
every 45 minutes I think that was like a
year and a half ago well I got so many
emails and stuff from girls after that
who related and we're like girl I'm late
for my flight too many women like me out
there with vaginas like mine and we feel
alone because you don't see vaginas out
and about that look like yours when you
have one like mine especially in porn
and I think that's the main place you
see lots of vaginas you know and they
tend to show up a lot more than you see
at Target yes that's true like I I don't
see vaginas I think the first time I was
like seeing other vaginas was porn and I
go where's mine like I couldn't it was I
never saw mine never saw one that looked
like yours yeah I felt like a young
black girl watching Disney movies I'm
like make one with me
one with me and oh you did and there's a
FRA I'm a frog half the time cool thanks
but there are so many girls like me and
now I see them because I I spy on girls
in my locker room at the gym and I see a
lot of hermit crabs looking for new
shells if you know what I'm saying
you just replaced the soup rice with
something much worse that's yeah yeah
it's it's a vagina like mine like
there's just a lot to deal with
masturbation becomes a problem like it's
just there's just so much to get through
and even finding my clitoris I mean I
know that's a whole thing of like well
where is it I'm like I don't know
like I don't know when you don't know
where your chorus is I don't blame men
I'm concealing a Rolodex like I pretend
I'm a Navy secretary for you sir and I
look I believe it's under sea
you can use a post-it that would be
hilarious to keep my space without a
post-it I'm gonna use that a bookmark so
remember where it is but yeah it makes
masturbation I mean I'm likes I wasn't
here I go again like I wasn't even
planning this but like I'm so frustrated
by masturbating recently like it takes
me so much and I think it's because I
got a lot goin on down there but man I
got like I used like three different
toys I'm sitting on one just cuz it's
like it's there and I don't want to
neglect it something on it get your
money's worth
yeah and I got it on a dimmer switch so
I'm working it with my elbow then I got
something in me I got something on my
clip I feel like a one-man band
[Laughter]
[ __ ] thing wow that was incredible
mine work you just did now I feel and
I'm so jealous of guys whenever I'm
asked for a demo is just like it's so
easy to be a guy you just do that and
that's so easy
it doesn't it doesn't come out of our
check I don't know what guys you've been
seeing at the circus but we're never
gonna air this
[Applause]
this is literally the symbol for when
something is easy you go that's how easy
a masturbation is for men it's like that
you this is what we've only done stop it
I'm so sorry you'd have a nun backstage
you can rush out here hitting you with a
cane or something